we all make mistakes we're all human and
it really is time now to find that
forgiveness for yourself otherwise
you're going to stay stuck in a cycle of
blame guilt shame and self-punishment
and i know from personal experience that
is hell on earth
[Music]
so i woke up that day and i was really
excited because
it was our school sports day that
afternoon i really thought i was in with
a chance of getting a medal
[Music]
i walked over to the runners box
and
i picked the javelin up
i took a really deep breath
and then i threw the javelin
as hard as i could at the very last
moment it veered to the right and headed
towards my friend sammy i saw the
javelin striker in the head
just above her left eye
she stumbled forwards and there was a
lot of blood
i just collapsed onto my knees with my
head in my hand saying oh my god oh my
god
i just couldn't process what was
happening
the accident was all over the news all
over the media and i think
my family wanted to try and protect me
from that but nobody really knew what to
do and so i was really sort of left
to get on with things on my own i
already had a very difficult
relationship with my stepfather and on
the way back from sammy's funeral he
said that we were never to mention her
name in our house again and so
not only did i not get any professional
help to come to terms with things i
couldn't even talk about it at home
i just felt like i had to
pretend to everyone that i was okay when
really i was feeling all of this mental
and emotional turmoil
after that therapy it was like a weight
had been lifted off my shoulders in the
moment when i realized
that i'd done nothing wrong i also
realized
all the pain and suffering that i had
created for myself
when i talk to people about
self-forgiveness
i've never experienced such pain in the
room it's far greater than when i talk
to people about forgiving others
self-forgiveness
cuts the core of our identity
people often go on journeys of
self-discovery
and this cassian's a very good example
of that took decades for her
to move
to a place of forgiving herself and in a
way then moving beyond forgiving herself
because she realized she was a child it
was an accident
there were adults there who should have
taken the entire
responsibility for what had happened on
the school playground that day so the
accident had happened but then it was me
that had created these really
destructive beliefs about myself that i
was evil that i deserved to be punished
and i'd gone on to punish myself in many
ways over many years and when i realized
that it was like my heart broke open and
i developed self-compassion
and
really needed to forgive myself for
hurting myself
for so many years
i think self-forgiveness is very much
wrapped up with guilt and shame
this is why i think accepting yourself
for who you are is critical to
everything it's about having this
broader perspective on life so for
instance in the case where you may
you may have had a drug addiction in the
past and caused a lot of damage to
yourself and others you may then
actually broaden your perspective to
look beyond yourself why have this
happened it's an addiction it's an
illness and that can really make a
change to how you perceive yourself and
how your life progresses
[Music]
by talking to others by exploring other
people's stories that are similar to
yours
what happened to them how is it similar
how is it different and then i think
key to everything is
self
awareness going on a journey to discover
who you are knowing yourself better
because if we don't know ourselves we
become deluded very often and we create
great damage in the world there's a
wonderful quote by the spiritual writer
richard raw
he says if we do not transform our pain
we will most assuredly transmit it so
now i make it my mission every day to
really practice love and self-care i
meditate every day i make sure i get out
in nature or exercise i have a really
brilliant support network of friends now
and family i'll reach out for
professional support if i feel i still
need it and now the thoughts i have
towards myself are much more loving and
accepting and forgiving
some people have said
that
self-forgiveness is selfish
i don't think that's the case at all
because if you can't forgive yourself
you are central to your drama
and you're probably telling everyone
about it all the time or if you're not
it's in your head all the time
self-forgiveness is about making peace
with things you've done which you cannot
change and also it's about accepting
that you are a fallible human being just
like the rest of the human race
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video